When it comes to exploring space we can either
all agree on a set of laws that make everybody
shiny and happy, or it’s like the gorram
Wild West up there.
Ni hao, browncoats, Julian here for DNews.
Laws are tricky things.
They’re complicated and they change from
place to place and over time as new issues
arise.
Like going to space.
See, when the Space Race was launched with
the starter pistol that was Sputnik 1, the
assumption at the time was that a nation’s
sovereignty would extended past their airspace
and right on into space… space.
And right off the bat those pesky ruskies
had violated it, what with their little pronged
ball zipping over ‘Merica, beeping at us
all menacing-like.
But no one made a fuss over it the way they
would if a Russian plane flew overhead unannounced,
because in order for a satellite to stay in
low earth orbit, it has to travel at almost
28 thousand km an hour (17,300 mph).
At those speeds there’s no way satellites
can’t fly over other countries.
It’s impractical to claim the space above
your country if it’s just going to get violated
every 90 minutes.
So should we just say nobody owns space or
everybody owns space?
Sputnik made it clear space-law needed a rethink.
Ten years later the 1967 Treaty on Principles
Governing the Activities of States in the
Exploration and Use of Outer Space, including
the Moon and Other Celestial Bodies, AKA the
Outer Space Treaty, laid the ground rules
for space etiquette.
Anyone who violates it has to answer to the
United Nations.
104 countries have since ratified the treaty
and it has a number of guidelines that basically
say space and celestial bodies are for everyone,
except if you have a weapon of mass destruction
that's a no-no, nations are responsible for
their own public and private stuff that gets
put up there, and please do your best not
to litter.
That’s another issue Sputnik brought up:
space clutter.
Ever since its launch we’ve been filling
the skies with more stuff.
How do we make sure satellites are clear of
each other’s orbits?
The UN keeps a registry of objects launched
into space, but because space is so huge the
odds of hitting something are pretty slim,
making the need to worry about two satellites
colliding almost a non issue.
So far it’s happened only once.
That’s for low-earth orbit satellites (which
are most of them), but some satellites are
a special case.
Geostationary satellites orbit so far away
that they go around the earth once a day,
making them basically hover over the same
spot.
Because these satellites have to be at a very
specific distance and over the equator, there
are a limited number of slots for them to
occupy.
Another UN agency, the International Telecommunication
Union, coordinates 191 countries and 700 private
organizations to make sure everyone's satellites
aren’t bumping into each other and that
no one’s frequencies are interfering.
Applicants are basically assigned parking
spots in space that the satellites have to
get to, and they can only stay there for so
long before someone else gets the spot.
So, long story short branches of the UN are
in charge of making sure everyone plays nice
in space, and countries make their own rules
for space travel within that framework.
But more challenges loom on the horizon.
It’s still unclear what we’re supposed
to do about space debris and who is responsible
for damage that wasn’t caused by negligence.
We’re also going to have to figure out how
to handle commercial human spaceflight or
shipping.
Hopefully it gets figured out before we live
in a Joss Whedon universe of smugglers and
eccentric characters with quippy dialo- you
know what I’m just going to cancel that
thought before it’s finished.
All this space stuff may seem far away and
irrelevant but it does have an effect in your
daily life..
To learn what NASA has done for you, check
out Trace’s video here
So now that you know space law is a thing,
will you be the next Phoenix Wright: spAce
Attorney?
Or are you more the lawless space-pirate type?